hello all
right welcome uh it's good to be talking
to you today uh today I want to talk
about some technologies that uh we've
been developing that allow the brain uh
circuitry to be mapped and also to be
controlled and the impacts of these
kinds of Technologies um and you've
heard about some of the kinds of
applications that people can pursue with
this in the previous talks um are that
we can try to decipher the incredible
density heterogeneity and high speed of
operation of brain circuitry so our
group is a Engineering Group we take a
very specific
approach um and the neuroengineering
discipline that we follow is to think
backwards from the physical complexity
of the brain and then try to figure out
what principles scientific principles
exist that tell us how to go about
analyzing and Engineering the brain for
example what is the nature of the cell
types of the brain what is the nature of
the connections between neurons and the
brain and what kinds of handles can we
use to control and read out the
electrical activity of the
brain then we survey the fields of
Engineering in order to try to figure
out uh whether materials or proteins or
devices or robots we can actually then
go forward and try to build technologies
that can help neuroscientist solve basic
or clinical Neuroscience problems so
today I want to tell you about nine
short stories um many of these are new
and unpublished bits of work uh that we
are excited about and the first set of
tools I want to talk
about are the optogenetic tools these
are technologies that let you take
neurons install photosensitive proteins
that convert light into electrical
energy of some kind and then by aiming
light at a certain set of cells you can
activate them or silence
them then of course you can put Optical
fibers into the living brain the brain
doesn't feel pain so you can install
these optical devices in the brain and
then activate sets of neurons or silence
sets of
neurons in the wild three different
major classes of molecules have been
discovered over the last half century by
biophysicists ecologists and cell
biologists who are interested in
figuring out how cells photosynthesize
and sense light the first class of such
molecules was found almost a half
century ago and this is the bacter
bacterial ropin these are light driven
proton pumps that exist in ARA single
cell procaryotes and these molecules are
seven transmembrane proteins that
contain an all trans retinal as the
chromophor the light absorbing molecule
and when hit by light it'll translocate
a proton from one side of the membrane
to the other so if you look uh into
salty water such as you might find in
the San Francisco Bay or the Great Salt
Lake in Utah or in the Dead Sea you can
actually see organisms that have highly
colored membranes and when um these
organisms uh sense light they actually
can convert that light into stored
energy
a second class of such molecules also
seven transmembrane proteins that have
an all trans retinol within them are the
Halo ad opsins and these were discovered
about a decade later these molecules are
light driven chloride pumps they convert
light into uh the transport of chloride
from one side of the membrane to the
other and that also allows you to store
electrical energy in the cell that then
gets transformed into chemical energy
Downstream finally around 10 years ago
several molecules light driven ion
channels are found and these molecules
sense light but then convert them into a
dissipation of of cation gradient these
are the channel adoptions light driven
cation channels that pass primarily
protons and sodium but to a lesser
extent calcium and potassium and unlike
the first two which are pumps these are
channels so they cannot be used to store
energy but they are instead used by
single cell algae to sense light and
then navigate to towards safe effective
levels of light for
photosynthesis all three of these
classes of molecules have known Crystal
structures for at least some of the
members of the class and um what we've
been doing over the last decade or so is
finding that each of these classes of
molecule the light driven proton pumps
the light driven chloride pumps and the
light driven carine channels from left
to right can be used in
neurons there's a couple reasons why
first of all these molecules have very
high High speeded temporal responses
upon illumination they actually achieve
their ion transport within micros
seconds to
milliseconds now not all these molecules
expressed in neurons we've had to Screen
through uh different molecules from the
wild to find ones that are safe
effective and function in neurons they
have to have the right speed and
magnitude of current in order to
function so on the left we found in a
paper that we published in 2010 that one
of the member of the light driven proton
pump family the arrod dosin could be
virally delivered to neurons in the live
mouse brain and then you could
illuminate those neurons with a yellow
or green laser and accomplish neural
silencing we called this molecule arch
in the middle column um in 2007 we
published a paper where we took a light
driven chloride pump at Halo adops and
put it into neurons and showed that we
could quiet down neurons with yellow or
orangish light the currents though are
small which is why we went on to find uh
Arch
and then the third column are the
channnel ad opsins light driven C
channels those are actually the first St
put into neurons in 2005 um and by
expressing these molecules and neurons
we showed that we could with millisecond
time scale blue light pulses excite
neurons with pulses of of blue light and
cause them to fire Action potentials one
of the nice things about these molecules
is that the alltr retinol the vitamin a
derivative that they use to um sense
light is found in Dodge ly in the melean
body so this was sort of a coincident
finding first I think reported by Yo's
group that channel opsins will function
in intact brain tissue from mammals you
don't have to add any
chemicals so the search for these
molecules really began in 1999 to 2000
there is a paper from a group in Japan
here shown where they showed that
electric current ploted versus
chloride uh for the Halo ad opsins was
actually not optimal for brain function
because the proteins would function best
at very high chloride levels like five
molar chloride and the brain of course
um as has you know in the 100 m chloride
range on the right hand side though you
can see that this paper showed that
there was one of these molecules the
Halo adops from the species of ARA and
fonus which had its peak function
exactly in the Mion chloride
concentration range and so that was the
reason why we took this molecule put in
neurons and show that we could quiet
down
neuroactivity now this molecule is not
very strong it didn't function very well
in neurons and so it actually I think
there's only one paper where people have
used this original andonis Hopsin to
change the behavior of a mammal and this
was done by yamus group they put this
molecule into the hypocretin OR ereen
expressing neurons in the hypothalamus
of mice by engineering them
transgenically and they then implanted
an optical fiber to silence these
neurons these neurons are of course the
neurons that are compromised in patients
with narcolepsy and when they illuminate
those cells what you see is that the
neurons will be silence and what happens
then as you can see plotted in the top
graph is that the probability of
weightfull um obtained that were better
and uh uh Brian cha and shahan now
assistant professors at upen and bu
respectively found some molecules um
that were much more strong one of them
that this is the arch molecule was a
light driven outward proton pump and as
you can see on the left lower left these
molecules had much higher photocurrents
uh at both low light powers and highl
powers and on the right you can see that
the neurons can be shut down with light
in the awake behaving Mouse
brain
in the years since we've continued to
look for molecules in different species
and we have now surveyed literally over
a thousand genomes for molecules with
different functions and I want to tell
you about some of these now including
some new unpublished
data one Insight is that if you search
locally in genomic space that is you
look for molecules from species that are
related to the species of a molecule
that you already like that could be a
powerful search strategy so the mole we
found Arch from halum sudens um has many
relatives and we found a molecule Arch T
that was found in a related species and
Arch T was effectively 3.5 times more
light sensitive than Arch and so we
published this a couple years later and
this was the molecule that enabled
perhaps due to its light sensitivity the
first oogenetic control of a primate
neuron with neural silencing that could
change a primate behavior in work done
in Bob W's group at
NIH in addition to searching locally in
genomic space you can search broadly in
genomic space for example the Halo dosin
are as a rule driven by yellow to orange
light and have much less exitation in
the blue Leed Brown several years ago
had found that funguses actually also
have light sensitive proton pumps and um
we took one of those that he had
discovered the leosia maculans opsin
which we nickname Mac and it's more blue
light sensitive so by putting a Halo
ropson in one set of neurons and the the
mech opson or into a second set of
neurons we could differentially silence
them with red versus blue light enabling
Multiplex control of multiple neurop
populations that's useful if for example
you want to shut down one set of neurons
and then briefly afterwards shut down a
second set of neurons and see how those
two sets of neurons might be working
together to impact a downstream
Target so that catches up to the publish
work on silencers and I want to tell you
about an unpublished story uh which is
about a new set of silencers
there's another reason to seek different
colors of light uh because we want to
um uh use red light to silence neurons
because red light can go deeper into the
brain so in some modeling work as well
resw Well's experimental work done by
Lea Aker and my kener group uh both
through modeling and measurement we have
shown that red light can go far deeper
into the brain than than green light for
example um and in fact if you look on
the right hand side you could imagine
that red light can with appreciable
efficiency get almost all the way
through the entire Mouse
brain so Amy trong in our group has been
leading an effort to find and engineer
new molecules that are red shifted and
more powerful so that we can do red
light neural silencing or non-invasive
optogenetics this is important for
several reasons first of all
non-invasiveness is very important for
many studies of neural pathology and
also in some Fields like neural
development implanting an optic fiber is
Not Practical because the brain is going
to physically change size and if you
have a fiber implanted and the brain is
changing its volume the fiber might
cause a lesion so Amy uh found and
engineered a new molecule L named Jaws
which is red shifted and also much
stronger than earlier optogenetic
tools for the effici AOS this is how we
found and made Jaws we first screened
through genomes that we had hypothesized
would contain red shifted molecules due
to a chance observation we had made made
in an earlier paper in the middle panel
we then found two point mutations that
vastly increase the photocurrent and
then on the right hand side we added
some trafficking sequences that did not
increase photocurrent but made the
expression more
clean if we compare Jaws to other Halo
ad opsins and the EMP PHR 3.0 is a um a
expression boosted Halo ad opsin from
Garo and Dio uh what you can see in the
middle pot is that the percent
inhibition with
with red light is far better than with
an earlier Halo ad dosin so even with
modest red light Powers we can silence
neurons expressing Jaws these are
virally delivered to the mouse brain um
and then illuminated with a local
optical fiber and with uh even with the
brightest red light delivered the EMP
PHR 3.0 the enhanced trafficking earlier
Halo ad opsin was unable to mediate
strong Neal
silencing Jess carden's group at Yale
University uh was interested in the
following question many silencers are
studied for their impact in silencing
spontaneous neuroactivity but many
neuroscientists care about stimulus
evoked or behaviorally Associated phas
eight neural activity um in fact perhaps
most neuroscientists focus on that so
her group took Jaws expressed it in the
visual cortex neurons in the mouse and
then showed these mice drifting visual
stimuli like gratings um and then try to
figure out whether they could silence
these stimulus evote responses as you
can see here earlier Haler adoptions
could only silence perhaps 1/ half to
2/3 of the stimulus evote neural
activity of visual cortex
neurons the arch adops Arch and Arch T
could do better but Jaws um was as good
as the best um and was the strongest
halopin by
far now on to non-invasive neural
silencing we virally expressed halopin
Jaws in deep cortical targets and then
put an optical fiber on top of the skull
of a wake behaving mice and show that we
could actually silence neurons many
millimeters deep through the skull in a
weake behaving mice so this fulfills the
goal of achieving um a minimally
invasive strategy for uh uh silencing
neurons in the the brain future
directions could include shifting these
even further out to the infrared and
also looking for um which might be of
importance for the developmental
neuroscientist completely noninvasively
Illuminating the brain through the skin
even so that no surgery of any kind is
required now i' like to talk about
activators so whereas optogenetic
silencers let you delete neurons
temporarily to assess their necessity in
generating Behavior or pathology
optogenetic activators let you play back
neuroactivity to the brain and can be
used to assess the sufficiency of neural
activity to initiate a behavior of
pathological
state
in 2003 Noel hegan and bomberg had
reported the discovery of Chan ropson 2
this light gated c channel I mentioned
earlier they also commented that such
molecules could be used to um change
calcium concentration or to poize the
cell
membrane so around 2004 um Carl dith and
I decided to try this out and um uh
working in my grad school lab dick Tren
group I gave this a Spin and actually
found out on the first try so this was
very serendipitous that we could express
these in neurons and then use blue light
pulses to excite neural activity and so
that's actually I think the very first
cell that I recorded and you can use
blue light pulses to excite neural
activity in this paper that we published
in 2005 we showed that varying kinds of
pulse sequences of light could elicit
complex patterns uh of timing of action
potentials and also if you drive
excitatory or inhibitory neurons you can
cause the synaptic release of
neurotransmitter in a time since many
groups have been working on um
augmenting these molecules um and uh
many groups have for example shown point
mutations that can for example increase
the current the h134 r point mutation of
chops and 2 in the middle of the slide
you can see that some of the molecules
can be used to speed up uh some of these
mutations can use to speed up the
protein function that is you can have
faster action
potentials um but one of the problems
although the font seems to be a little
overl wave on this version of the of the
slide um is that uh speeding up the
molecule does result in making the
molecule less light sensitive and
similarly you can increase the light
sensitivity of the molecule with the
c128 or d156 mutations but this has the
effect of slowing down the molecule in
effect speeding up the molecule closes
the molecule faster uh after light um
turns off and that has the effect of
also reducing the number of ions per
photon that go through so um that's one
idea why speed and light sensitivity
were thought to be inversely related
finally at the bottom people have been
trying to Red shift Channel ad opsins as
well and people have made through
chimeragenesis and genome mining green
light activated Channel opsins but
nobody up till now has made one that has
a peak in the yellow or is high
driven by red
light so in a paper we just published in
nature methods last
month we collaborated with G Wong um and
the Beijing genomics Institute to mine
over 120 species of algae to identify
over 60 new channel Ops in a quest to
see if we could solve these problems
could we find a true red light activated
Channel opsin which can be activated
with brief pulses of light can we also
find molecules that are both fast and
light sensitive and this is work that
was led by Nathan ketki currently a
postto in the
group the screen uh yielded 61 new CH
opsins those are plotted on the homology
philogyny tree on the left and on the
right are the outcomes of the screen for
the most interesting CH
opsins on the top you can see we were
delivering red light to neurons and we
found one molecule um
which we nickname Crimson which could be
driven by red light and then as you can
see in the lower two bar graphs there
are green and blue light excitable
Channel opsins many of which have much
higher performance uh in terms of
photocurrent than earlier
molecules this is the action spectrum
that is how much charge you transport
versus color for Crimson the new red
light driven gener opsin and earlier
molecules including the green light
driveable ones that were generated by
several other groups
earlier so Crimson has a peak around
almost 600 NM and as you can see with
red laser light say from a 633 NM laser
you can have effect efficacies that are
between 50 to 80% in terms of
photocurrent uh that you can
achieve
okay so now with Crimson you can excite
neural activity with good time
resolution and modest light power in the
red we found a point mutation of crimson
Crimson r that also makes the kinetics
um as high speed as some of the earlier
molecules like the h134 or Newton of
chopon 2 and so you can get out almost
to the infrared we're using 735 NMM
light in this bottom plot and work that
we did in collaboration with Mark that
Conant patents group to excite neural
activity and you can see in the lower
right hand corner Spike probability
versus pulse width um with 735 NM light
of modest light power um if you have
pulse widths and then 20 to 40
millisecond range you can actually have
almost perfect Spike probability of of
elicitation so we're excited to go
further and see whether truly infrared
light can be used with Crimson as well
um and there's obviously a lot more that
we could do uh in terms of mutagenesis
in order to shift that out even
further let me give you an example the
kinds of things you can do with Crimson
in addition to Red Light activation
which as we've already talked about is
of interest in the Manan
brain uh this is work that was led by
vvec jarman's group at Jania farm and he
had pointed out to us that Ina one of
the major model organisms of
Neuroscience and biology it's been
difficult to get good oxygenic control
because of Behavioral artifacts that are
elicited by visible light in the in the
right hand bar graph you you can see
Star responses that is the Flies will
flail their arms and show other kinds of
behaviors with just regular light no
optogenetic tools but if you look in the
at the final bar if you go into the
red 720 NM then the stter response can
be greatly reduced if the animals are
also hi
everybody so
um um shall we continue the The
Talk
okay
great so to summarize the Kronos
molecule is uh not only very light
sensitive but very high speed and that
is um makes Kronos perhaps a good
General use chops in for controlling
neuroactivity with great
Precision now Kronos and Crimson could
be used together there's a long-standing
goal in AOG gentics of Multiplex
activation if you could activate at two
different sets of cells you could
imagine uh for example activating a
neuromodulator pathway like dopamine and
then trying to activate a fast
neurotransmission pathway like a
glutamate pathway and seeing how the two
Pathways interact you know for example
do they reinforce each other or interact
in some other
way here you can see a brain slice
expressing both Kronos and
crimson and when we activate with blue
light or with red light we can get
synaptic
activation now this does not prove
though that we can get truly independent
control one worry is that blue light
might dry Crimson a little bit and
Crimson is driven by red light and red
light might drive
Kronos now it turns out if you look at
in the spectrum that red light photons
that drive Crimson would not drive
Kronos perhaps because the red photons
are quantum mechanically too weak but
the problem as you can see from this
slide is that all opsins are to some
extent driven by Blue Light that's
because of the intrinsic retinol
chromophor
absorption so one idea is what if we use
red light to drive crimson and remember
Kronos is very light sensitive so we can
use dim blue light to drive Kronos so
dim that it won't engage Crimson to any
significant
extent as noted light sensitive
molecules up till now were reported to
be slow but with Kronos finally it's one
that is both light sensitive and fast so
serendipitously we've done a triple
optimization we found a red shifted
Channel opsin and a light sensitive fast
blue channel
dosin so what you can see here is um the
middle uh an attempt to try to
characterize Kronos and Crimson spike
elicitation in visual cortex brain
slice with red versus blue light and if
you look at the very middle panel of
this five panel
figure you can see basically neural
Spike probabil ability in visual cortex
brain slice of crimson expressing
neurons at the top and cronis expressing
neurons at the bottom with red light as
you can see Crimson expressing neurons
can be fired 100% of the time with red
light across this light power range and
cronic expressing neurons um are never
fired by red light so that's sort of the
easy direction right the red photons are
just too weak um in the fourth panel
though you can see that uh it we use
blue light power chronis expressing
neurons can be driven by blue light and
Crimson expressing neurons are not
driven by Blue Light uh with perfect
separation over a range of light powers
that is delimited with a light blue
bar and if you do synaptic transmission
Cris expressing neurons can be perfectly
driven with blue light to drive synaptic
release but never with red light and
Crimson expressing neurons can be
perfectly driven with red light but
never with blue so that gives you
um a light power range for blue and for
Red where even in Impact brain tissue
you get zero cross talk at the spiking
or syntic transmission level in intact
brain tissues so to summarize Crimson is
not only a red Chanel opson that allows
you to do new kinds of experiments for
example reduced Behavior artifact work
in
flies Kronos is a Ultra high-speed ultra
light sensitive channel opsin that might
be a good all-around Chann opson for the
the future but together they uniquely
enable zeroc cross talk two color
control of two different sets of neural
Pathways in intact Mamon brain
tissue in the next phase of the talk I
want to talk about making more iron
selector Channel ad options this is new
unpublished
work yucho a former postto in the group
now an assistant professor at the
University of Connecticut developed a
high throughput microscopy platform that
lets us rapidly go through Wes of
mutants and screen for enhanced chops
and
function using this we were able to
screen literally hundreds and hundreds
of point mutations and by doing optical
activation of these mutants an optical
readout of for example calcium sensitive
dyes we were able to find mutations that
reduce the calcium flux by an order of
magnitude and that reduce the proton
flux by an order of Mag magnitude so
given that calcium and protons are ions
that can have multiple functions
independent of their voltage control um
we name this channel drops Chrome a
channel drops that that omit certain
ions and therefore this might be of
interest for um you know studies where
one wants to use optogenetics but
without uh potential effects that
calcium for example could result in like
changes in gene expression
pattern um and so on and so
forth and the next story I want to talk
about a new project on making
optogenetic tools that can actuate
endogenous molecules so far we've talked
about heterologously expressed molecules
from bacteria and fungus and
algae that can be expressed in neurons
to control the voltage but what if you
want to activate endogenous
molecules Daniel Schmidt a postto in the
group developed a strategy to do this we
took a different photo receptor domain
the LA domain shown in blue and yellow
and by tethering it to the membrane
through a transmembrane domain and by
fusing it to a gene that encodes for a
peptide toxin we can make a new protein
architecture that we call the Luma toxin
when you shine light on it the light
activated uh domain the law of domain
acts like a light activated hinge and
opens up moving the peptide toxin away
from the Ion channel or receptor that it
binds to and there are thousands of
peptide toxins from snakes and spiders
and
uh cone snails and so on and so there's
a vast repertoire of such things so now
you could imagine that we could activate
this with light move the toxin away and
actuate an endogenous Channel by moving
the toxin that blockades it away from
it so this works in this slide you can
see this working with dender toxin which
blocks um KV channels potassium channels
and if you just look at the lower left
hand corner you see an orange Trace
where a Blue Bar indicates a period of
blue light delivery and what then you
that you then see is an increase in
potassium Channel current that then dies
away when uh the light is turned off and
the black Trace is a different Channel
showing that the toxin specificity is uh
retained one power of this is that this
Luma toxin oogenetic tool architecture
is
modular you can see three different sort
of 3x3 grid on the left
the orange uh bar is alpad dender Toxin
and then the next row is DTX K and the
bottom row is conents in one and what
you can see in each of little boxes is
that each of the toxins when embedded in
the Luma toxin architecture will enable
upon elimination actuation of a subset
of the potassium channels and the native
toxin Affinity is
retained on the right hand side you can
see the actual change in the currents
that you that and as you can see the
current changes are sometimes small so
in the future we want to make these
things much bigger and
also to see if we can um enhance the uh
range of molecules that can be used and
finally also to make Luma toxins that go
in the other direction when you shine
light on them they blockade the channel
rather than unblocking the
channel in the next phase of the talk I
want to talk about tools we're
developing for automated single cell
analysis in the living Maman brain and
this includes robots that can do neural
recording and also robots that can do
surgery over the last several years
we've been collaborating with Craig
Forest Group at Georgia Tech on a
project led by suaza kandaya working
across our groups on automating invivo
wholesale patch clamp so patch clamping
of course is a great technology
basically you lower a glass Micron
needle onto a cell and open up a little
hole into the
cell and when you do that you can get
Exquisite neural recordings with
synaptic uh event
resolution you can also inject chemicals
such as florescent dyes into the cell to
visualize the shape and you can also
harvest the contents in order to do um
for example transcriptomic analysis to
look at self typ information at the
molecular
level
in Vivo wholesale pouch clamping is
difficult only a small number of people
around the world do it so we discovered
an algorithm um that lets you lower a a
pet into the brain of a mouse and then
over many consecutive steps to um
achieve uh recordings um we lower the
AET into the brain we do a Time series
analysis of the pipet
impedance and that alls us to detect
with high
accuracy we then built a robot that lets
us do these recordings and that's
actually been commercialized by a
company that my anti-d disclaimer is I
have no Financial link to um and this
company is now developing uh kits where
people can take a patch clamp system and
make it
automatic so for example we can do in
Vivo automated awake behav U Mouse
experiments uh on
pharmacology here's a collaboration with
Emory Brown where we're testing out how
different anesthetics affect different
cell types in the beginning we have
patch cramp a neuron and the animal is
experiencing one kind of anesthetic
which leads to one pattern of synaptic
and subal
activity then we wake up the
animal you can see this around um
letters c and d and then uh you see a
different pattern and then we add a
second
anesthetic from all outward appearances
the animal looks like it's an estize
because it is but if you look at the
neural activity and the neural processes
within you can see that it almost looks
like the opposite of what was happening
in the beginning so many mechanisms of
brain science have been worked out in
vitro in brain slice or in neuro
cultures but until we understand how
those mechanisms play roles in the awake
behaving brain um it's hard to know just
how important any one molecular or
synaptic or ION channel mechanism is for
a given Behavior or pathology so one
hope is that we can build automated
mechanism Checkers that can allow you to
investigate uh which mechanisms play
roles in the awake behaving brain and
contribute to different diseases or
therapeutic
outcomes along those lines we've
continued to work on trying to scale up
these robots so we could record from
many cells at once and also to do many
other kinds of manipulations like
infusing drugs and so on into the
brain to achieve that we also have been
working on trying to automate other
kinds of um Neuroscience skills inv Vivo
automation is relatively new although
arguably inv vitro automation has proven
transformative with for example the
sequencing of the genome or the ability
to do highit pharmacological screening
on Cell lines or synthetic biology so we
decided to try to figure out how what
that you might call invivo robotics
would do next and so we decided to try
to figure out if we could automate um
some of the steps of of Neuroscience uh
surgery Nikita pck
a grud in the group has been working on
um a way to lower a drill bit through
the skull and trying to stop then when
we get just through the
skull as you can see from these CT scans
we can actually drill through the skull
and um without human intervention uh get
pretty much all the way through and stop
without brain damage so not only can
these uh inval automation uh experiments
enable sort of the democratization of
Neuroscience no longer does one need to
learn very very difficult nvo skills to
do Neuroscience um although of course
the thinking is extremely important but
also these automation strategies can
lead to scalable impact so um if you're
like me thought the thought of drilling
you know a large number of holes to the
skull in order to examine many different
pharmacological agents and different
brain regions sounds very daunting but
as you can see from these x-ray images
of actual mous skulls after we used our
Auto surgery machine this canot be done
um in a fully automated
fashion so
summarize um with invivo robotics we're
very excited about automating some of
the most difficult skills perhaps in all
of biology but also we can then try to
achieve scales of of invivo
experimentation in awake behaving
mammals that are difficult to achieve in
any other
way the final thing I want to talk about
is accessory tools um making
ontogenetics and these other tools
practical requires many strategies that
enhance the function of the work we have
uh built wireless optogenetic
devices um that can allow you to do
remote control of the brain with no
cables or Optical fibers that might be
of interest for studying development or
chronic disease progression or other
kinds of of useful um uh studies um this
is being commercialized Again by a lab
spin out company that again I have no no
link
to we also have been working on a
collaboration that was work this work
was led by Christian Wentz um and Jake
Bernstein we've also been working uh in
with several groups including Nancy
Capel Randy Butner and grael and Chris
Moore on combining fmri of the brain
with opto gentics and we published a
strategy that enables those two
technologies to be
combined uh groups such as hu Zen's
group at the Allen Institute have made
transgenic mice that Express these
optogenetic tools so that you can um
um without having even to use viruses
use optogenetics to study the brain and
finally u in work we've been doing with
in collaboration with Cliff fad Anthony
Zoros um a post talk in our group now
has been developing 3D optogenetic tools
that can deliver light into the brain in
3D
patterns on our website synthetic
neurology.org um there are links to many
of the Technologies um we distribute
these tools uh freely probably to well
over a thousand groups at this point
we've lost track a bit because many of
the distributions are handled by
nonprofit such as ad Gene which is the
DNA distribution the University North
Carolina which distributes viruses I
already mentioned the transgenics from
the Allen Institute and if you go to um
uh we launched a new center MIT the
center for neurobiological engineering
if you go to our website there's a way
you can actually apply um to come by and
and uh observe experiments for a day or
so and to learn how to do these kinds of
experiments
so um there's a form there that you can
fill out and we've hosted probably about
300 groups at this point um who have
sent somebody for a day or so to to
learn neurot
Technologies on a closing note it's
interesting to think about with all
these tools do they have a translational
future in the sense that they're in
widespread use to study basic science
and to study diseases in animal models
that could they be used in humans
directly
so for neural control perhaps over a
quarter million people already have some
kind of neural stimulation implant for
electrical
stimulation and uh in terms of the gene
therapy because of course we need to
deliver an oogenic tool to the brain
with the virus um there was just the
first aav approved gene therapy approved
in Europe and many trials are ongoing
and uh uh report support um significant
safety for the aavs so one of the
questions is well what about the
molecules themselves these oxygenic
tools come from plants and bacteria and
so on are they
safe in 2009 in a collaboration with Bob
desimon and Graal uh shiran L a project
where we did the first prate oog
gentics um and we showed that we could
elicit neuroactivity with oog gentics in
awake behaving non-human primes the Reis
m
we also collaborated with rodri Bronson
a pathologist to look at um samples of
tissue and also we looked at uh the
serum to see whether antibodies are
being produced and uh although it was a
small study just two
monkeys um uh there is no over evidence
of a productive immune response nor cell
death nor um other things that might be
wondered about such as immune cell
infiltration in the years since um other
groups for example wiim Duff group has
been able to activate neurons in the
non-human primate non-human primate
brain and change the behavior of the
non-human primate and as I mentioned
earlier Bob W's group has been able to
shut down neurons in the non-human
primate brain and alter non-human
primate Behavior so it is of Interest
perhaps to think about whether as these
studies continue such tools that allow
you to activate or silence neurons in
the brain could be used for therapeutic
purposes so to end there this is
obviously vast collaborative project on
the left- hand side our acknowledgements
I think I've mentioned all the team
leaders of projects along the way um but
the the full group is a highly
interdisiplinary disciplinary group and
on the right hand side are are
collaborators in various projects I
think I've mentioned all the team
leaders um that we collaborate with on
on those projects um and um I guess we
have some time for questions now so
thank you very
much
all right so the Q&A button is blinking
at
me and there are some
questions um so one of the questions
is how do you target um selective
neurons so one of the strategies that's
uh of of widespread use is the fact that
for many model organisms like mice there
are literally hundreds of mouse lines
that EXP Express a specific enzyme cre
recombinase under a specific promoter so
for example um this person has asked
about the direct versus indirect pathway
neurons of the of the striatum for
example the direct pathway neurons will
Express D1 receptor and the indirect
will Express D2 receptor so you can
actually get D1 receptor crise and D2
receptor crise if you put a vector a
viral Vector into the brain um and Scott
sternson I think was the first to
publish the architecture that most
people use nowadays um the flex Vector
you can deliver this virus to the brain
and only in the neurons that Express cre
combinat will the virus be
active so you uh this actually been done
by anatol criter for example I think you
might have been the first to do it for
direct versus indirect they took the D1
receptor creis and injected a a virus
into it and the virus could infect
multiple cell types but um only the D1
receptor cre uh expressing neurons would
actually activate gene expression for
those
neurons and there yeah as I mentioned
and their databases like if you look up
gensat for example they have made
hundreds of cre cre uh recombinat
expressing mice and many of these are
available from nonprofit institutions
like Jackson lab and
others the next question is what are the
uh sort of kinetics of silencing
activation of neurons using
optogenetics so for Activation you can
deliver you know one millisecond scale
pulses and for silencing you can shut
down neurons um for you know people have
done up to hours so it really is driven
by your scientific
question the next question was about how
optogenetic tools and invivo recordings
cont to the goals of the brain
initiative so by way of background the
Obama brain initiative is aimed at
developing new tools for mapping
recording and controlling brain circuits
starting with model organisms like mice
but with ambitions eventually to go to
humans and uh many of these tools are
indeed um technologies that are forming
the backbone of the brain initiative um
or future versions thereof will be
generated in response to the brain
initiative uh funding so one of the
ideas for the brain initiative is
whether you can scale up the recordings
uh can you do invo recordings that you
where you can record thousands or
millions of
neurons um throughout the genetics uh
there are many groups um are using
optogenetics as part of brain initiative
related projects and uh if you could for
example activate many neurons in the
brain and figure out how um Activa
neurons one by one drives connected
neurons that could be very useful for
mapping the functional connections of
the
brain the next question was um what time
duration was uh elaps between the uh
beginning of the primary experiments
probably the gene delivery of the
oogenic tool and the pathology essays
these uh durations were not very long
just a few months um so very often of
course um we're not uh doing prate
experiments by ourselves there's other
groups that do pregate experiments
because they're studying attention or
cognition and then we try to piggyback
with them and uh help them use our
Technologies to help them answer
scientific questions in return we uh try
to get back some information of clinical
importance so these are not glp you know
GMP Style experiments that um you know I
think would be necessary for for proving
safety let's say at the FDA level
there's sort of projects that we're
doing that piggy back on other
scientific experiments on the other hand
though um if that's a way of
bootstrapping these experiments and
galvanizing interest in them um and to
motivate others to do uh the kinds of GP
or GMP style experiments which require
you know much more significant you know
commitments of time and financial
investment that's something that we are
excited about and there are some now
companies uh that are funded to do
optogenetic therapies and um one hope is
that some of these companies will take
on some of this um activity that might
be not very easy to do in a in a small
academic
environment um next question is about
opof fmri uh the comment is that
optogenetics is millisecond time scale
but fmri has poor temporal resolution
and that's true for us too so when we
optogenetically activate a neuron we can
do that at say 10 pulses per second or
100 pulses per second but the fmri is
still fmri so when we see the change in
brain activity of course fmri Works
through changes in blood flow neurons
are active uh and then the dominant
Theory right now is that neurons signal
to gal cells and gal cells regulate the
vasculature and then that changes the
blood flow um and that's what you
measure with fmri and so the hemodynamic
response functions for of fmri are
pretty much identical to the hemodynamic
response functions for regular fmri so
we're talking about time constants in
you know the seconds to tens of seconds
and um all of the caveats that accompany
that on the other hand you can imagine
the use of
opof uh in the following fashion maybe
use opof fmri to map the entire brain so
you can figure out what regions a given
cell type in a given brain region can
engage then you can go in with
electrodes um maybe such as the
autopatch device and try to do then
extremely high speed extremely high
fidelity recordings um and in a way that
fmri cannot so one idea is that opto
opto fmri can be useful for a couple
things one is for analyzing fmri itself
so we could try to interpret human brain
scanning where fmri is one of the only
games in town the other is to use it to
do preliminary mapping of brain circuits
for later follow-on
studies which uh would use a higher
resolution neural um monitoring
technology such as pouch clamp elect
recording calci Imaging or so
on S I'm going to sip some water
here these are all great
questions okay the next question was um
what was the web page which was about
applying to come to
visit um so uh I C direct a new center
at MIT called the center for
neurobiological engineering we have 24
faculty um who are the initial members
of the center and one of the core
activities of the center is to
facilitate the teaching of
neurotechnology so we've started um uh
excuse me bit of a cold
here um what we call the neur technology
training program and the website uh
where you can download a PDF and fill it
out and then email it to our
administrator um
is web.mit.edu
CNB which stands for Center for
neurobiological engine engineering
there's a link on the top of the page
called
sharing and you can then click on a link
there um to uh apply for I guess what we
now call the neurot technology exchange
we used to call it the neurot technology
training program and uh fill that out uh
we want to make sure that people have
enough background um uh knowledge so
that the training is not um uh you know
so so over the person's head that it's
sort of meaningless you know we we can't
train people on basic uh Mouse handling
or other very basic Neuroscience skills
so if somebody wants to come in and
learn for example in Vivo optogenetics
or in Vivo um Auto patching or other
skills we want to make sure that that um
they know the basics that we can teach
them our technology but we don't have
the bandwidth or resources to teach sort
of fundamental things like how to pick
up a mouse or how to you know do very
basic things like inject a drug or um
you know sort of uh um that kind of
thing uh but we've I think we've accom
ated pretty much all reasonable requests
that we've gotten over the years and
again members of over 300 groups have
have come out to to
visit all right next question how do you
identify all the cell types in the human
brain yeah this is a very hard question
but it's an interesting one
because the cell types of the brain um
are not well defined we currently we
meaning neuroscientists sort of
anecdotally Define cell types by shape
or by one or a few proteins they express
or some even by the firing
patterns so I think one of the big
questions first is how do you even know
when you found a cell type is the gene
expression pattern enough or do you need
do you need the morphology or do you
also need to know the physiological
roles in the
brain also are cell types static do they
change um over time we know that many
genes in the genome for example are
regulated by circadian rhythm so one
question might be are cell types static
or not you can imagine a scenario where
you start out with two cell types and
their gene expression patterns change
over the course of a day uh to the point
where at 3:00 in the afternoon they are
now the same cell type and then they
diverge I I don't know of any evidence
for that but I just want to point out
how complex a question this is so um one
strategy of course and this is another
brain initiative focus is to develop
tools that would allow the mapping of
the cell types of the brain and probably
we need the gene expression patterns and
the shapes and the physiological
recordings so one of our projects
actually and we're expanding this into
many different directions now is to take
strategies like our single cell analysis
robots and enable individual groups to
do their own cell type mapping because
celltypes might also also vary as a
function of disease or age or
plcity all right well almost out of time
for this there a couple more questions
and I think we can get to them the next
question is about does this technology
help address the substrates of
Consciousness uh this question might be
be beyond my pay grade but um uh I think
we need to have a good definition of
Consciousness so that we know when we've
actually found what we're looking for I
do think that we need a lot of
Technologies if we ever want to get to
the point where we can for example hope
to mechanistically address questions
like Consciousness so um if we could for
example record neural activities and see
that certain patterns are correlated
with Consciousness what Kristoff K and
Francis Crick called the neural
correlate to Consciousness or ncc's
that's one area that could help another
very interesting possibility is that if
we can stimulate neurons in complex
patterns and see that those can drive
various kinds of Downstream Sensations
or
decisions that could help as well but
those I think are are questions that
that are just beginning barely to be
asked one could argue
um and in part I think understanding
what Consciousness is at a at a
definitional level is something that is
is even by itself challenging how do we
know when we found it
right that said many people are using
these Technologies to study properties
that everybody I think agrees are
helpful and contribute to Consciousness
like awareness and attention and being
awake versus being asleep um and so
already op genetics and these other
tools are being used widely to try to
address those building blocks that we I
I think everybody thinks is important
for Consciousness but probably aren't
the whole
thing okay next
question how long until genetically
encoded Optical neural activity
indicators are from being used
practically yeah so there are many
groups working on genetically encoded
florescent reporters of neural activity
you know so our tools allow you to
control neur activity with light another
direction is to record neur activity
through light emission from cells and
people have tried both bioluminescence
where neurons sort of blink at you when
they are active as well as fluorescence
where you deliver light to the brain and
then the neurons will emit a different
wavelength of light than the incident
light this field is I think experiencing
a bit of a Renaissance right now for
example last year um a group at janelia
Farm published a paper reporting a
genetically encoded uh fluorescent
reporter of neural activity a calcium
reporter called gamp 6 and this molecule
was sensitive in enough that they were
able to map neuroactivity at different
points along a dendritic branch of a
single neuron in the intact brain so I
thought that was pretty cool they even
showed for example that you might have a
neuron whose spiking output was let's
say non- selective but different parts
of the neur neural dendritic tree could
be select for different kinds of things
and the neuron then sums all those
things together and they kind of cancel
out so that's something of course that
you could never do with a Petr let's say
or some other kind of non-invasive
electrical recording um uh
methodology so so I do think that we are
seeing um an acceleration you know the
first genetically encoded calcium
reporters were published almost two DEC
two decades ago um with atsushi Miaki
and and Chen for example um and now I
think we're finally seeing examples
where they are being used to answer
questions that you cannot answer using
other Technologies so that's very
exciting all right the next question on
the list is do you take in consideration
the pH level of the brain fluid when do
when doing your research great question
so Katy just published a paper in neuron
couple couple weeks ago they expressed
Chen opsins inle real cells and what
they show is that when you activate
chops in in Gia you actually get pH
changes and Gia are pH sensors and so
the Gia actually release transmitters in
response to pH changes mediated by Chann
opsin so I like this paper because it
shows that these molecules don't just
control electricity in some Anonymous
and uncharacterized fashion but you know
it's ions right ions actually Implement
electrical changes they went on to show
that archuro opsins the light driven
proton pumps that we talked about
earlier if you put them in the Gia they
ship protons the opposite way and they
actually showed that this could exert a
neuroprotective effect so they had a um
in a in a mouse model a way of getting
brain damage um and then what they
showed was that if you optogenetically
inhibit neuron uh the G cells with Arch
the brain damage is prevented and so
that was sort of the pest resistance of
their paper that antigenic tool can be
um can have ion specific effects and
they could have sometimes very complex
Downstream um changes so I recommend
that paper highly to everybody um for
many reasons it's a a non-voltage use of
optogenetics it's a use of optogenics in
Gia which is very interesting but also
they show how the downstream effects of
an oogenic manipulation can have um you
know very interesting uh uh signaling
properties um that can have bold
consequences in our analysis of the
brain so that's all the questions on the
bucket I guess I'll turn the
conversation back over to the
hosts and I thank you for your
time